now the world economic forum is 50 years
old this year but
its golden anniversary wasn't bigger and
better than ever before with the
coronavirus pandemic making in-person
gatherings
a no-go world leaders came together over
the internet instead
as well as driving the forum online the
virus also
dominated its agenda
davos hasn't been this quiet in decades
no signs of the usual hustle and bustle
instead
a thick blanket of snow the locals like
it that way
i enjoy it there are no gratings there
is little traffic
it is quiet there's fewer guests i would
be happy to not have the wef here
anymore
everything is open no security checks a
lot less people
of course i like it
will the locals enjoy however is a
painful sign of what has happened to the
world over the course of the past year
online world leaders offered their plans
and solutions
with regards to the ongoing pandemic and
stressed that international cooperation
is key to overcoming the crisis
china will continue to take an active
part in international cooperation on
copit19
containing the coronavirus is the most
pressing task for the international
community
we need to choose a multilateral
approach a self-isolating approach won't
solve our problems we see that first of
all in the question of vaccination
since it's the root out of the pandemic
we are all not safe if some countries
are vaccinating their people and other
countries
are not vaccinating we all must act
together in combating
coronavirus because it affects all of us
equally
working together across the globe an
event streamed on the world wide web
might be a good start and yet there is
hope
that the forum can return to its usual
grounds
again
well joining us from davos is adrian
monk managing director of the world
economic forum welcome to dw
business i mean we heard some of the
world leaders there
that cooperation particularly when it
comes to vaccines is going to be a key
way
of getting out of this pandemic do you
get the impression from what you've
heard this week that there is a
consensus
building on how to do that
thanks for that i'm actually in geneva
where the world economic forum
spends about 360 days of every year
um so davos is just somewhere we uh we
go for one week of the year
uh i think what you've seen in davos
this week is nearly 30
world leaders heads of state coming
together to tell you what they're going
to be doing in 2021
to ensure that the virus can be
brought under control and that really
does mean vaccines
that also involve some of the major
vaccine producers and having this
opportunity at the beginning of 2021 to
really bring all those people together
have some of the conversations both
publicly and privately
is a really really important uh move and
that's something we've been able to do
with this virtual davos in a way
almost unparalleled i mean it's almost
been easier
to coordinate some of those
conversations online than in real life
there's also a lot of insistence that
any pandemic recovery has got to be
sustainable from what you've been
hearing are you confident that there's
going to be a concrete effort
to actually bring that about
what we've seen this week is something
like 50 different measures from
businesses and governments that have
been coordinated
uh both publicly and behind the scenes
here uh online
and you know one of the major
announcements really speaks to
to that exactly which is this
announcement on so-called esg
measures that's environmental social and
governance measures you've got 60
of the world's biggest businesses and
corporations coming together
to actually do something to track how
they make an impact on society on
the environment and on the way they do
business and that kind of move i think
is pushing us in the right direction so
that when we come
out of this crisis we're not going to be
left with the same
old rule book that got us here in the
first place
a big change since the last forum which
a lot of people
will remember is the man in the white
house do you think
that having joe biden as president of
the united states has
made the tone somewhat different this
year
a new administration means big changes
for everyone
and uh you know joe biden is no stranger
to
the world economic forum he's been with
us as vice president a couple of times
he's been to other meetings that we've
held around the world
so you know we know the president and uh
you know we're looking forward to
working with him we had john kerry his
climate czar speaking this week
on the plans that the united states has
to really
get back behind the wheel in terms of
driving
uh the agenda on climate change so i do
think there's a whole number of
different ways in which this
administration
will make a difference but it's not just
the us you know i think one of the
things we've seen
through the crisis is that every single
major economy has a role to play
and i think hearing from those leaders
and seeing that we're now in
very much a multi-polar world has been a
big part
of what davos this week online has been
about
yes it has been online it's been without
the the private jets and all the
trappings of the usual
davos agreement davos this year could
this online
wef be here to stay
funnily enough uh you know you say that
but actually private jet traffic into
davos is known more than during a busy
week in zurich
art fair uh in actual fact emissions in
davos the town
go down during davos week so the air is
cleaner
purer and nicer when we're in town than
when the locals
are left to themselves with buses cars
and everything running through the
center of their lovely
alpine uh town but
uh it has made a difference to us in one
very important way it's enabled us to
bring in
many many more people into these
conversations and you know the impact
online
has been enormous it's something like
five or ten times
the number of people who normally join
and the world economic forum has
something like 30 million followers
across social media
that number has gone exponentially
higher this week
so it really has been for us a fantastic
experiment not one we planned for but
nonetheless a great experiment in
bringing in new voices and really
sharing what we're doing
online adrian monk managing director of
the world economic forum
thank you for joining us on dw business
thanks very much
you